welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's always
hunting for the one like agent smith in
a matrix glitch and the second trailer
for the matrix resurrections is now here
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down what could be happening in
the movie some of the leaks on the film
and also giving our reaction to it full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything ruined then i recommend you
dodge this video whilst you still can if
you enjoyed kia new please drop a thumbs
up for the worst puns in the game that's
meant to be keanu and without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown of the matrix
resurrections trailer has to be one of
the worst one of the worst puns i've
done on this channel now like most
second trailers there's not a whole host
of extra stuff in this one but we do get
more things fleshed out as to what's
gonna be happening there's also some new
characters shown here and because of
this we can kind of piece together
certain things i think it's become clear
at this point that a lot of the leaks
for the film are indeed true and though
i don't want to out and out spoil the
movie i am going to be talking about
some of them just to give some context
to exactly what we see now one of the
main things that people are confused
about is how the timeline in the film is
working for example we have a younger
morpheus who's being played by yaya
abdul mateen but a neo and trinity who
are the same age this trailer also gives
us our first look at a person that i
believe is niobi though i'm not 100 on
this she is wearing clothes like she's
in the real world and according to
rumors on the film she will now be the
leader of the human race it seems like
at the end of the third film that both
trinity and neo's bodies were restored
and their minds were placed back into
the simulation there were several things
brought across from neo-subconscious and
this is why we have elements like the
black cat the blue pills to keep them
sedated a coffee shop called simulate
and several other aspects from the first
movie now just in the same way that
characters like the architects sati the
merovingian and probably agent smith
have been brought into this new
simulation i believe that morpheus
himself will be a machine we've seen a
moment in the trailers where it looks
like the character is being created and
i think if we think about the timeline
for the film then that makes a lot of
sense my guess would be that neo and
trinity were kept in the machine world
and they were given special pods to live
in which meant that they aged a lot
slower outside in the real world though
time continued as normal morpheus died
niobe became the leader of humanity and
a rebellion started up that wanted to
take the machines down the matrix itself
may have been created to bend itself the
neo-subconscious keeping him somewhat
trapped and unaware of exactly what's
going on this may be why his reflection
is altered as seeing his own face may
trigger a memory the rules in the first
film said that you appear how you want
to appear in the matrix so perhaps the
way he looks is a way to stop him from
discovering the truth it's clear that
trinity's memory has been wiped too and
i believe that all the pills therapy and
so on have been put in place to keep neo
sedated bumping into trinity could end
up triggering a mass event in which
their memories come back and thus they
start off a chain of events that leads
to them escaping now how they do this
appears to be through morpheus and also
bugs bugs has several moments in the
trailer that look like they're repeating
scenes from the first film namely the
one in which she's caught on a computer
by police much like how trinity was as
for how they'll escape it seems like
mirrors play a big part too in the first
film they were of course how neo managed
to exit the matrix after taking the pill
here they are very much used as doorways
and in the first film the phrase through
the looking glass was used quite heavily
this pulled from alice in wonderland
which we saw in the first trailer was a
book that neo came across at one point
the idea of the matrix surrounding all
the characters is used to great effect
and i think it's brilliant how in the
moment that morpheus looks into a mirror
though we can see water droplets on it
that resemble the code there's also the
dojo fighter is clearly mimicking the
first movie but it's a much more
destructive sparring session this time
around because of this i almost feel
like neo will be very similar to people
that morpheus talked about in the first
movie and that he'll actually not want
to leave the program in the red dress
scene morpheus discussed how there were
people who would fight to keep things
the way that they are because they have
a good life and looking at how rich and
successful at neo seems to be i feel
like he might fall into this category it
seems like trinity and the idea of
saving her will be what pulls him out of
it and that's why it's brought up so
much in the teaser but let me know below
if you disagree if we are really in his
mind here it seems like neo has created
a fake life for himself looks like he
sedates himself with blue pills which of
course calls back to the first film as
it was in that that we saw these led
someone away from escaping the matrix
from what i can gather from the tv spots
and trailers neo is a game developer
that actually worked on a trilogy of
games for warner brothers that was also
called the matrix this is super fourth
wall breaking and it's gonna add so much
meta stuff to the movie if that's the
case there's even a moment in which we
see a scene from the matrix playing in
the movie itself making my head explode
trying to figure out what's going on as
i've said i think his subconscious will
be very much what this world is built
around and that everything in it will
pull from elements of his mind i think
by the looks of it that this movie will
be tackling mental health themes and
highlighting people who question their
reality and if there is indeed some
legitimacy to it this is given further
away by the therapy session in which neo
spends time with the analysts played by
neil patrick harris he'll be very much
keeping neo in check and referring to
him as anderson which was the
character's name before he was freed i
think the last thing they want to do is
have neo and trinity wake up as they
could possibly help the human rebellion
that i'm guessing are still angry that
we're being used as batteries if the
woman is indeed naobi then she's very
much hinting to the war coming and
possibly she doesn't want to disrupt the
symbiosis that humanity has achieved
with the machines i'm guessing it all
comes to a head at the coffee shop which
we can see is called simulate simulate
becomes simulate if you remove the tea
and coffee is of course something that
wakes you up when you're tired this
could perhaps hint at how near will wake
up and it also has the green color
that's associated with the matrix code
it seems like it's at this location that
they both become aware and whereas in
the original trilogy only neo had the
one super powers it seems like trinity
has them here too and actually love it
if the twist was that it was trinity who
was the one who built everything and nia
was trying to keep things in place
because he'd found somewhat of a
paradise there is a lot of focus on her
in this trailer and it's clear that
morpheus wants to push neo into saving
her i love how there's also the mention
of how she didn't make it past a certain
point and this is of course referencing
how she died before making it to the
machine city center however at least in
this movie they do make it past that
point of the skyscraper together so it
seems like they'll be going towards the
final scene as a team the bits from the
movie within the movie are said to be
from neo's memories but trinity would
remember these moments too and she'd be
able to see neo which i think could be
teasing towards it being in her head now
when the first trailer dropped there was
a big tease towards who jonathan groff
was playing and i think it's become
clear now that it will be agent smith
there is a scene in which you can catch
the character with his mouth sticking
together and i think it would be great
if this was carried out by neo smith of
course did the same thing to neo in the
first matrix film and it would be a
great little switcheroo now we also get
a much better look at the menacing ship
which is replacing the nebuchadnezzar
this is actually named after the greek
goddess of memory which of course ties
into the overall theme of the film
now as for my thoughts on the movie i
know i should be really excited for it
but i think no way home has just kind of
sucked all the air out of the room i
really wish they'd released this at the
start of december or even january as i
think the same week as spider-man is
really gonna do it as service the movie
definitely deserves to be talked about
and it's a shame seeing it overshadowed
when we've had any other point in the
air that they could have dropped it out
but didn't it's also of course dropping
on hbo max in the us on the same day as
it releases in cinemas so i don't know
how the box office is gonna do but i'm
definitely gonna go see it on the big
screen though the franchise has had its
ups and downs it still changed the
action genre and i love that they're
leaning into as much fourth wall
breaking stuff as possible as it's gonna
be such a head trip i was one of those
kids who saw the first movie and thought
the matrix was real so i can't wait to
watch this then explain to my wife why
i'm downing pills in a nightclub and
running around after a fit bird with a
rabbit tattoo anyway that's my problem
and not yours but obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the new look we
are running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the
spider-man 4k trilogies on the 30th of
december and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
will you pick the comments at random at
the end of the month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now say
that to you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the first look at
spider-man across the spider verse which
will be linked on screen right now we go
over all the cool little easter eggs in
it and also how it hints towards other
spider-man showing up so definitely go
check it out right after this if not
then thanks for sitting through the
video you've been the best i've been
poor i'll see you in the next one take
care peace